بقيت نايمه انا وياه عند دار اخوه افطرنا
وقال لي ياما قومي طروه على على دارك
اخذته ومرنا وقفنا شويه هيك في وسعه قدام
الحمام اللي بيقول لي يما ارفع اصباعك
بالاشاره طبعا ما يتكلمش قال هيهم اليهود
حوط الباب تعالي انا نمر وين في الغرفه
مرقنا في الغرفه في عند تخت نمت انا وياه
عليه ق بقول لي هيهم مرقوا الدار
مرقوا الض قال لهم اجوا اجوا باشر لي اجوا
اجوا قال لي قومي اليهود مرقت جوا صاروا
ايش يحكوا لمنير مش عارف ايش حكوا له لهم
قال لهم مي مضر نزلت انا جاب العكاز ما هو
معي عكاز انا حطه قدامي على اساس يشوفوني
دفعوا الباب الغرفه ومروا ولا كلمه اكلموا
ولا هويتك ولا ايش اسمك ولا مين انت ولا
حاجه زقونا ورا الباب وقف اليهودي اثنين
واحد طويل اشقر وواحد قصير اسمر
لشقر سلط على ابني نقر ويا في رقبته
مباشره بدون اي ولا كلا ولا قال له وين
انت ولا اسمك ولا
هويتك حط له حط له الساح في حط لا مش حطه
من بعيد طخه اليهودي نشن عليه طلقه واحده
وقع انا وقعت عند ابني لو صار يقولوا لي
قومي قلت مش قادره اقوم قال قومي قومي قلت
له مش قادره اقوم ابني مرمي على الارض
مسكوني الاثنين اليهود ومسكوني من ايدي
ارفعوني ما قدرتش
اقوم لو بقول لي امسكي هون انا حفه التخت
مسكت ما قدرتش اقوم مسكوني الاثنين بموتهم
ورفعي لو بقول
اليهودي ارفع فستانك رفعت يعني الجيش
بيطلب منك التعريه يعني تفتيش انه ترفعي
ملابسك اه رفعت جلابيتي الحمد لله بقيت
لابسه بنطلوني رفعت رفعت الجقول لفوق لفوق
تشافوا بطني قال خلص انز خلص يعني احنا
بنحكي انه الجيش بيقوم ايضا بتعريه النساء
في في داخل بيوت اه اه هذا اللي صار معك
انت اه هي اللي صار رفعوا بطني وشافوا
بطني اه شافوا بطني انت شافوا بطني انا
بقول يلا اطلع من
هون اعدمو اعدام نقر نقرو بعد ما تم اعدام
ابني ا طلعوني من
الدار